thomas qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir des
annonces ce soir du président américain
eh bien on peut déjà retenir que joe
biden confirme l'évolution de la
tonalité de la maison blanche concernant
les décisions annoncées ce lundi par
vladimir poutine pour le président
américain il s'agit du début de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie a
donc annoncé des sanctions dont on
comprend qu'elle son grade et elles
peuvent aller plus loin si la russie va
également plus loin en ukraine voilà ce
que déclare joe biden qui a donc
détaillé des sanctions économiques je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous ciblons deux institutions russes
financière libye et la charité
nous
interdisons nous bannissons
la russie aide des marchés financiers
occidentaux on ne peut plus faire
commerce de sa dette sur le marché il
n'y a plus eu accès
à partir de demain nous imposons
également des sanctions suit et les
élites et les familles des russes ils
ont partagé l'intimité de partage mais
également la douleur
avec l'allemagne nous avons travaillé
afin que notre strict 2 comme je l'avais
promis se fera pas
nous avons déjà préparé les actions
suivantes la russie paiera un tribut
encore plus fort si elle continue ses
actions contre les crèmes les états unis
continueront à apporter un soutien
militaire à l'ukraine et continuera à
renforcer et réassurer à ses alliés de
l'otan
voilà donc des sanctions économiques
annoncées par joe biden qui viennent
s'ajouter à celles déjà annoncées ce
lundi par la maison blanche je vous
rappelle qu'un décret a été signé hier
donc par le président américain pour
interdire tout nouvel investissement
échange ou financement par des personnes
américaines à destination en provenance
ou à l'intérieur des républiques
autoproclamées du don base joe biden qui
annonce également ce mardi le
redéploiement de troupes militaires
américaines défensives comme il précise
dans les pays baltes il est également
revenu sur les conséquences que
pourraient avoir ces sanctions
économiques sur l'économie américaine
joe biden annonce qu'il prendra des
mesures en ce sens et puis il est revenu
plus généralement sur le discours
prononcé ce lundi par vladimir poutine
qui est selon lui une attaque sur le
droit de le cren à exister il n'y a pas
de doute dit le président américain
c'est la russie qui est l'agresseur dans
ce dossier il faut bien comprendre que
joe bayonne subit aussi des pressions
internes aux états unis notamment de la
part des élus républicains qui lui
demande de faire preuve de la plus
grande fermeté possible contre la russie
on suivra désormais à cet après midi les
déclarations de la porte-parole de la
maison blanche qui va s'exprimer d'ici
quelques instants et puis on suivra
aussi la visite du ministre ukrainien
des affaires étrangères qui devrait
rencontrer son homologue américain
anthony blinken d'ici quelques instants
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas abonnés en direct de
washington m